the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video
well my friends the day we have all been
waiting for has finally arrived
house of the dragon has officially
started filming scenes for the first
season of the show
actors matt smith and emma darcy have
been spotted on set
and i must say they do look amazing i
want to give a shout out to the daily
mail for releasing these images
we now have our first look at daemon and
rhaenyra targaryen
as you can see matt smith sports blonde
locks as he joins co-star
emma darcy on the beach to shoot scenes
for the game of thrones successor show
this does confirm they are filming
scenes over in cornwall england
they might be using this location for
scenes of king's landing but i'm
thinking it's more than likely
dragonstone
let me show you what this article said
matt smith has been seen filming for the
hotly anticipated game of thrones series
house of the dragon for the first time
the actor who is 38 years old
transformed into the character of daemon
targaryen as he sported long blonde hair
and shot scenes on the hollywell bay
beach
in cornwall on tuesday it sounds like
someone actually got these photos today
emma darcy who is only 28 years old will
portray rhaenyra targaryen in the
upcoming series
i honestly think her scarlet dress looks
incredible the braid in her hair even
reminds me of daenerys but maybe that's
just me
i don't know about all of you but matt
smith is definitely giving me viserys
targaryen vibes
he donned a long black jacket in
knee-high boots for the shoot
and appeared to be deep in conversation
with rhaenyra as they stood on the empty
beach
i know i'm dying to find out what they
are discussing during this shoot the
actors were seen talking on the golden
sands and walking along the beach before
emma walked over by the water
over recent days speculation has been
rife that the series is being
filmed in the southern county after
workers were spotted in different
locations last week
on monday photos emerged showing a film
set had appeared on the hollywell bay
beach
suggesting that it could be used in
scenes featuring matt in emma and the
medieval castle on saint michael's mount
on mounts bay in cornwall where filming
is also said to be taking place
bears a striking resemblance to the
castle inhabited by cersei lannister
the castle has a breathtaking view of
the north sea with much of the filming
said to be taking place in the lower
reaches of the mount within days
now i know they have been using this set
for the home of house velaryon but i
really do think they could be using the
beach for dragonstone scenes as well
i'm sure we will find out more
information very soon
now that photos are hitting the internet
things will only snowball from here
i don't know how many of you followed my
channel during the filming of game of
thrones season 7 or game of thrones
season 8 but as soon as filming began
i was making videos almost every day now
that house of the dragon is filming
we will start to see new photos come out
almost every day as well
we might even see some long videos of
them filming scenes
and who knows maybe someone working on
the set that day will spill the beans on
what's actually happening
in those scenes we shall see if you are
interested in watching how this first
season gets made
i would highly recommend subscribing to
my channel now because as i said in my
last video
i will document everything each step of
the way
now i don't want to do too much
speculating about what could be
happening in these photos because it's
really hard to say right now
since they don't always film the
episodes in order they could be
discussing just about anything
if any more information is released i
will make a video letting you know as
soon as i can
i don't know about all of you but these
photos have me very excited
everything feels so official now one
thing i do know is this fandom is about
to get a lot more interesting now that
westeros is coming back to life
again i just hope all of you come along
for the ride it should be fun
let me know what you think about these
new images do you like the way they look
do you like their outfits leave me your
thoughts down below
as always i want to thank everyone for
stopping by to check out my quick update
video
i hope all of you have a great day i
will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you